in the race for the White House Joe
Biden is officially the Democratic Party
nominee for presidents the former vice
president will face off against
President Trump and a campaign already
upended by the corona virus pandemic Ed
O'Keefe joins us from Washington with
more on this ed how did he do this and
why did it happen on a Friday night
well good morning jeff CBS News now
estimates that Biden has the delegates
needed to officially clinch the
nomination 1991 delegates is the magic
number he's got at least 1993 with 10
contests yet to be held this is Biden's
third bid for the presidency so yes in
his case you can say it the third time
is indeed the charm he clinched it late
on a Friday night because some of the
states that held primaries this past
Tuesday were still counting ballots
thanks to a record number of mail-in
ballots due to the pandemic in a
statement late last night Biden called
it quote an honor to compete alongside
one of the most talented groups of
candidates the Democratic Party has ever
fielded Biden you may recall got off to
a bumpy start with poor finishes in Iowa
New Hampshire and Nevada but shot ahead
after a decisive win in South Carolina
thanks especially to support from black
voters he prevailed over more than 25
primary opponents including a record six
women in part because Democratic voters
believe he has the best shot at
defeating the president and recent
polling shows Biden leading mr. Trump in
a head-to-head matchup while other
surveys put him ahead in critical
battleground states like Arizona Florida
and Michigan but there are still 150
days to go until the election Biden has
to find himself a running mate has to
shore up support among liberal voters
who originally backed Bernie Sanders and
Dana like everyone else he's got to
figure out how to live work and in his
case campaign in the midst of a pandemic
it is is we're sick of saying I know the
new normal Edie okay thank you very much